the world mourns as its gods continue to
ignore them
laughing in their paradises as man
suffers
can they not hear the plea of children
clamoring out for more mandatory fun
more
chat rewards more viking cursing
more headlines
but the gods never answer our pleas
i say no
and there is only one solution
all gods must die
oh tommy what are you doing here hey
jessa well i was uh just getting ready
to watch some headlines they're pretty
dark today wouldn't you say uh not a lot
of
cheer uppers
yeah that makes sense but what's that
black stuff dripping from your mouth
yeah this is uh there was a really tasty
vegan black bean soup in the kitchen
someone must have left it i did not want
it to go to waste it's friday after all
okay i guess that makes sense too but
why do you have a sword oh this
is my news watching sword
come on jess
you don't have a news watching sword
it's 20 22. i thought everybody had a
news watching sword
tommy
get a news watching sword jessica
thor four in theaters now
stellar performance don't uh don't
discount jessica's straight manning
there uh welcome back to the break room
we're thrilled to be here
jessica's especially thrilled uh we're
thrilled that you're here um thank you
tommy for that that cold open that was
interesting little documentary footage
of what goes on here at the new rock
star office
uh we're gonna be talking about all the
nerdy news of the day uh including we
got a lot of miss marvel
conversation a little top gun news a
little madden web going back in time
plus very excited about this one member
of this panel could be getting a haircut
live on air
look at those luscious locks might be a
little less so close uh so um well but
before we talk about that
tommy we do want to talk about something
else that's right before we get to our
redemptions we want to announce that the
break room now has an official tick-tock
at the underscore break room follow us
we're going to be following back you
know what we're just little baby tick
tockers going back yeah you follow us
we'll follow you back you're getting it
on the ground floor okay stitch us duet
us come to our houses plant flowers in
our garden that we don't know invasive
species bring some cicadas to my
grandma's house to scare her all right
join our tick tock we need you now more
than ever and by the way so while i got
your attention pony up the dough today
okay
pony freaking speaking of that okay so
all week hey already the storm virgil
thank you yeah that's my guy
your storm uh all week we've been
talking about if we hit a thousand
dollars total in redemptions
tommy bechtold is going to get a haircut
care of
jessica clements
who has informed me today that she did
not ever guarantee she'd be good at it
i because you kept saying you said
jessica swore by it and i was like i
never swore well i've been known to
exaggerate i don't know how long have we
all known each other i don't know you
guys uh tommy said i'm the bully he
bullied me into this world
are you kidding me oh my gosh you have
no idea we are close to that thousand
dollars yes
we're currently at for the week eight
hundred and forty three dollars oh god
we're already gone oh
no me master my man
wow
dropping hammers okay thank you movie
master well that kicks into instantly
the second phase of this jessica do you
want to tell us about that um we're
going to set up a poll for you guys to
vote on which one we should give to
tommy uh those people that show up late
are going to be so upset they're going
to be like i didn't get to vote you
should have showed up on time uh so we
have the flock of seagulls
also known as the reverse small we're
calling this all known as the reverse
mullet in the front and then we have the
actual mohawk a nice a nice classy
mohawk nice we all like a nice classy
moment okay
actual mullet oh god
he's gotta officiate a wedding folks
i am officiating a wedding next week so
please be merciful oh and then last but
not least my favorite the ball the ball
don't hype the ball cut up i feel like
they're definitely
if anyone cares about me my personal
preference is the mohawk okay but i
don't care you guys can pick whatever
you want and i will honor my preference
is the bulkhead yeah we're gonna be
talking about will from stranger things
later i feel like that's a signature
look uh wow again thank you newbie
master uh so we've accomplished that
redemption we are going to be cutting
tommy's here live on air a little late
at the end of the show stick around for
the yes
stick around vote now we're going to
throw up a poll to pick the haircut then
a little later we're gonna based on the
chat i have a bad feeling it's gonna be
not what i want
um now we have another level of
redemption we've been teasing all week
uh that if we hit two thousand dollars
total for the weeks we still got a
thousand bucks to make today
we as a cast will pull a gentle minions
we'll go see informal where we'll go see
the minions uh rise of gru in theaters
uh this weekend or early next week so
we've got some distance to go i will
just go ahead and say i'm going out on a
limb if we can even hit 1500 i
personally will go yes okay i won't i
won't of course any of the other cats
to go they've got other busy lives i
will leave my family wow for multiple
hours wow
wow we're discounting back
here i even
as a tease here's a little preview
here's the here's the gentlemanly outfit
i plan on bringing okay look at this
because i bought this to go to another
way absolutely and i went too it's
really nice whoa okay uh td jones
getting us on our way oh please guys i
have to wear this hair all the time it
already kind of looks like a bowl don't
be bored
it looks like a little mushroom don't be
boring don't be basic i said stupid
banks all right listen to me i want to
go one step further if we get to 1750
zack and i will go to mrs harris goes to
paris wearing our fine and ferrous
which is we will wear tuxedos or suits
or whatever and we will go see the
worldwide phenomenon mrs harris goes to
paris and maybe we'll pick we'll do a
double feature and go see minions after
yes oh a double feature that's only at
17.50 i'm not messing around you're
already going to cut my hair
that's right all right we made magic
with uh it's morbid time let's see if we
can accomplish that today that's right
with the minions but first we need to
get into some headlines yes
um this is the main topic of today's
video believe it or not the thumbnail
wasn't about haircuts but uh
iman valani
friend of new rock stars yes friend of
new rock stars star of miss marvel uh
miss marvel herself did an ama on reddit
yesterday answering questions from fans
one of the things she revealed is her
pick for the next mcu big villain if she
had her say and it would be again friend
of the channel eric vaz's uh personal
pick mephisto yes
now
probably not
probably not showing up in marvel's
maybe not yeah we don't know probably
not a little tease of that but i mean we
could have had russell crowe is mephisto
mefiscro oh
hashtag mcfisk kraut yeah um she also
revealed in that ama that had she been
in civil war she would have been on team
tony
are you on team tell me tony's right
tommy is 100 he's been on record i'll be
honest tony's right a lot of politicians
flip-flop you have been on record for
now going on nearly half a decade sign
him up steve rogers has ptsd we should
not be listening oh my god okay okay i
want to distance myself from brainerd
the man's crazy also he's he's aided and
abetting a a
an international terrorist was killed
possibly jfk okay possibly kill jeff oh
my god we all know he was actually
murdered by his own secret service
members but possibly jfk wow your team
you're going to sign yourself with steve
rogers i think i don't want to quickly
apologize to my
uh
voters i will not be appearing in any
more fundraisers with brandon barrett
yeah we are running a separate campaign
in fact i have never been very close to
him i'm kind of surprised people are
lumping us together i hardly know the
man we barely spoke you know what we we
jumped right past it because of uh
newbie masters generous donation we also
triggered a reverse swear jar
we're still at every hundred bucks we're
opening up we're we're leaving behind
the uh viking curse words we're going
back to the good old-fashioned
swear jar so when you hit 100 bucks and
it uh unlocks uh a florent uh torrent of
uh
nasty words yeah from somebody on the
cast i think jessica gets it today she's
one she's wanted to go back i like that
jessica yeah
so do i drop some curses
uh
any of you guys that didn't vote for the
bowl cut you're a bunch of [ __ ] asses
and all you do is suck ass
vote for the bowl cut please
if you're in line to vote stay in line
okay you guys are still here i don't
know it looks like mohawk's taking the
lead and i think we should just end the
poll right now nope nope
uh why i want to look good i don't
understand why you're encouraging me to
look like an answer this is a boy
i will tell you what bull [ __ ] has not
been i i think i'd look really cool with
the mohawk i think i look really good
with the mullet as well do i get to cut
the sideburns cut whatever you want just
don't touch the beer and somebody
somebody who had a bowl cut from fifth
grade through ninth grade me too yeah
i've already had a bowl cut you know
what i've never had a nice mohawk
a nice mohawk
speaking of nice mohawks uh we got new
photos from the madame web set i think
these are the first kind of photos that
photos we've gotten
um now those look just like a regular
city street but the details are
interesting so that's a poster or a big
billboard there for beyonce's debut
album came out in 2003 and i think
there's um ads on top of those taxis
talking about um a certain kind of
wireless or something like that like 3g
3g a hotter thing in 2000 right
it's making us think and apparently
those those photos were taken in boston
but they're trying to make boston look
like new yeah mt on the ground yeah
taking photos uh massachusetts-based mt
um but
uh interesting they're setting the show
they're setting the film in the early
2000s i mean i think this is a great way
to tie it into the
rainy verse uh if there's this like a
madame web story where she's able to
you know cross universes and bring in
spider totems from wherever this could
be like another callback to like the
2000
run of spider-man with toby
do you think toby mcguire could show up
and madame webb absolutely not no he's
busy he's busy playing he's not getting
out of bed for that yeah his back hurts
yeah literally he got stabbed he got
stabbed when he was in his gang
huh you know he's in the gang with
leonardo dicaprio oh yeah
the alyssia posse
okay
uh oh adam scott also has a pee pee pops
in the people pee pee posse is uh david
spade
rob schneider
randy queen
look down
and that's where all you quaint maniacs
out there
okay uh
other man of web news adam scott has
joined the cast
on yet named roll uh this is the first
official male cast member we've heard
about maybe yes they've cast every young
woman in hollywood so far
this is the first male cast member adam
scott when i delivered flowers as a
young hollywood uh engineer
is that a code word yes delivered no no
adam scott this is a true story ordered
flowers for his wife and daughter every
single week it was a time delivery he
always met me at the gate and he was i
swear to you very often the only person
who tipped me that entire week that i
worked adam's always tipped adam scott
someone's wife and daughter we don't
know if it was
yeah yeah yeah
he would go he would come to it was his
house he would reach through the gate
and then he'd run
we've got some stories about some uh
certified not good folks in hollywood as
well yes for another day um oh speaking
of bowl cuts noah schnepp uh will byers
on stranger things gave an interview to
variety
in which he confirmed will will be a
central focus in season five yes okay
now this could go into thirsty thespian
territory but it's already been shot
right or at least it's in the works yeah
it's not him campaigning
he's not saying world needs a spin-off
series no no he's saying he will be a
big deal which is fitting we were
talking about it before he was kind of
the central focus of season one it's
nice to come full circle and have him be
the central focus of season two also the
other big news and something that's
heavily hinted throughout uh the most
recent season but um you know he's gonna
come out as gay yeah and that he's in
love with uh mike right i laughed during
that when you said that and i was
laughing at the chat of someone saying
hashtag shave down the middle
my friends neil and kristen who have
honored me by asking me to officiate
their wedding
this would be one way to have them never
speak to me again would be to just show
up with whatever this hair because
you're going to be photographed yeah all
of their memories of their most special
day
will include you with your ridiculous
haircuts correct um now one thing we
could do we could save all the trimmings
and you can form a tommy wig
hey uh for five years on the hit abc
television show in the middle i wore a
beautiful human hair wig i'm not afraid
to go back to the wig lifestyle were you
in a wig for um the one on hbo minx yes
i was
that's tommy's corner
that's the follicle friday update
uh follow friday follicle friday also uh
big marks office news here officially
top gun maverick has passed titanic to
become paramount studio's all-time top
grossing film
uh as tommy pointed out proving his
theory the movie audience is like
winners not losers who sink to the
bottom of the ocean when did you say
that
is this counting for like inflation no i
do not it's not inflation adjusted which
is everybody who's living in the modern
era knows there's a lot of inflation
going on right now you gotta pay you
gotta just see a top gun these days you
gotta pay 20. especially i mean well in
86 top gun only cost a nickel yeah yeah
also i mean lots of people see on top of
good maverick in imax which we were big
fans of yeah but that cost a premium as
well so yeah 20 bucks a ticket you know
i'm still sure that well that it's also
time so it's like top gun is still out
people are going to still be paying for
that more than they're going to be
paying for uh what was the titanic yes
well more than they're going to be james
cameron is
shook right now i mean he just he just
uh oh he's got he's got five avatars in
the church that's right
he's about to hit him don't you worry
james they never no
never gonna take your double vhs tape
sales record no double vhs tape has ever
sold more than titanic gold edition blue
edition
jewel of the ocean heart of the ocean
edition
pokemons right now
no that's what they are listen all my
titanic vhs stands know that i'm right
then i'm a real one i know there are
three different editions i own all three
okay
never let go never let go never let go
uh speaking of never letting go we want
to shout out our great friends at
hellofresh america's number one meal kit
we would never let go of hellofresh
they're sending out farm fresh
pre-apportioned ingredients and seasonal
recipes right to your doorstep
tommy you had a funny hello fresh
anecdote you were sharing with me before
we started taping this is actually very
true uh everyone saw my delicious pork
chops that i made the other day but
my girlfriend and i had a
miscommunication and for the past two
weeks we've been getting double hello
fresh deliveries because i still have
mine from when i signed up for our
promotion and she's been a years long
hello fresh subscribers so we've just
been doubling down on hello fresh meals
however i'm seeing they have the summer
recipes the the the old bay shrimp and
sausage boil yeah i gotta get you know
my girlfriend she doesn't like to talk
to me she basically when i'm there she
actually likes to look at me yeah and
not speaking you speak through hello
fresh yeah i'm a bit of an eye candy for
her but i gotta figure out a way to get
her to sh i can't use the app i'm not
good on the apps she's got to get that
old bay shrimp and sausage boil coming
my way hello fresh if you're listening
call in and let me know it's going to be
okay it is a live show hello fresh the
lines are open um
you can skip the grocery store like
tommy and his girlfriend do and spend
more time soaking up that summer fun uh
hello fresh market is a one-stop shop
for all your meal time needs uh we've
made hello fresh meals all week here at
the show we've showed off some some
pretty nice footage yeah uh credit to
producer john jessica and tommy yeah um
and uh they've tasted great and they've
been easy to make 30 minutes or less
come on yeah come on uh so um if uh go
to hellofresh right now right now yeah i
mean keep this window open but then open
up a new window hellofresh.com break
room 16 and use code break room 16 for
up to 16 free meals and three free gifts
to be named later
that's code break room 16. when you use
that code not only does it get you a
good deal on your hello fresh
subscription also makes us look very
good helps us bring this show to you so
we appreciate you for doing that thank
you to hellofresh
um
jessica
we've got some miss marvel news to
discuss the marvel miss marvel's head
writer bishop k ali which i'm so sorry
if i butcher your name again revealed an
interview with variety that the original
plan was to have carol danvers and
kamala khan meet during this season of
miss marvel but ultimately they decided
to put that on hold until the marvel's
built when asked about kamala meeting
carol on the show she stated i think it
would have been i think it would have
really taken it off in a different
direction if she'd met any sooner than
she will meet her which is in the movie
that's coming out next year
completely agree i think i i like that
they haven't met yet i like how they
have met yet so we have more to add to
the marvel's movie uh how do we think
that carol and kamala will ultimately
meet in the marvels i think sitting at
the uh cons family dinner table
where carol has just been served a
delicious meal and then uh
uh kamala comes in and goes uh
kamala kamala sorry i do the vice
president's name uh kamala comes in and
goes uh what are you doing in my seat
hang on let me give that read again
what are you doing in my seat oh yeah
i think i like the idea that boss had
yesterday that she's in the negative
zone and they're gonna have to try to
get her out but she actively is doing
her own part and trying to get out i
think we're going to assume that she's
weaker than what she is and clearly
she's not after getting the ambigan and
doing all the stuff and the ending i
think she's like i'm capable of getting
out of the negative zone without yeah
she's awesome she still has a bangle uh
do you think do you agree with me i
think she has the bangle i agree with
that okay
i think
yeah i mean her being in the negative
zone is interesting i like the idea that
yeah she's way far away from earth
now the negative zone is just like on
the other side of
the dimensional veil or whatever but i
like the idea that she's very
very far away uh because carol being on
earth is not like a threat to her
because she could just fly away she's
like oh well i just went back to the
start and now i got to fly back now vaz
was proposing in the breakdown for
episode six came out on the channel
yesterday that there was a little bit of
a freaky friday body swap going on yeah
i didn't get that from watching it and
my first viewing was just like they
physically swapped places right but
that's not when we see carol at the end
of that episode that's not iman in
carol's body i think people are attached
to that because that's what happened in
the comments yeah
in this interview she they she was kind
of asked that uh she's like no
absolutely not like they swapped places
because yeah in the comics
kamala's first like uh pterogenesis
thing makes her look like miss marvel
carol danvers uh and then you know i
think rightfully so like we're not gonna
do that story uh for this show yeah uh
but that was yeah at first it's like uh
are they doing that that's kind of crazy
but it's clear that carol's more freaked
out that she's like i'm in this room
that's a shrine to me
this is weird
yeah now do you think wherever
i'm in most intrigued like where was
carol
that she just got pulled yeah like where
did she get pulled from because we're to
assume kamala got sent to wherever like
they swapped right so like they kind of
like took each other's place and like
wherever that was because we've kind of
like we've been out of touch with
captain marvel right right since the end
game and in the mcu how many years has
it been since endgame finished it's been
like two years because it was 2023 so
now it's 2025 and we saw her like in the
end credits of shanghi but she was like
on a video screen doing something and
also when they swap she's like in casual
mode like she's i assume is still
wearing her armor because it has good
things
right but it's not jammies no sleeves
uh there's no head here
you know she's not in fight mode even
the swap didn't make her like power up
she doesn't come in like glowing or true
i think she uh what i would really like
to happen is if she is just with the
other bangle with the cree and she's
just talking to them about the bengal
they're like
a room talking yeah and as soon as she
like touched it she switches with kamala
and kamala shows up and that's where the
crees meet come on we should we should
honor we have some great polls that have
been done including one specific to this
but let's go first with madame webb
taking place in the early 2000s do you
think we see toby mcguire of
neck and neck race wow getting 50
yes getting 49 in that one percent just
floating out there somewhere uh
garfield himself he's gonna say andrew
garfield is smashing the maybe button uh
and then also this top gun maverick
movie a better movie than titanic no
titanic was the greatest again by the
narrowest of march there was a lot of
debate in the chat uh yeah after we we
sprung that on wow
that might be reflective i mean there
should be a recency bias obviously most
people probably i haven't seen titanic
since it came out i genuinely love half
of titanic is incredible
half of it yeah the bill paxton parts
are amazing it's not like anything
related
i mean the fact the story behind it is
more incredible in fact that james
cameron really just wanted to go find
the real titanic and was like i will
make a movie yeah if you let me go
and find the right i cried at one of
those movies and it was definitely
titanic
i sat next to my mom and when kate
winslet got naked she went like this and
covered my eyes and i was not a young
man if you know how old i am so that was
pretty embarrassing hi mom also people
in the chat being like i never saw
either of them that doesn't make you
cool yeah yeah that's not cool we don't
care that you don't own a tv yeah um you
got it uh whatever
movies you made a ton of money um i do
like you know circling back to kamala
and carol uh i i do appreciate that they
didn't introduce carol to the very end
because you know there was i didn't
agree with this but there was a big
counter argument with hawkeye it's like
oh this is more of a kate bishop show
little hawkeye show or whatever that was
you saying that all the time
i did that voice
you said my name but griff
but i do like that
even though we and we are we're already
taking like kind of some big detours to
like you know pakistan and like going
back in time to the grandma and stuff
like that so i'm glad that we didn't
then need to take another like one or
two episode detour to go into carol
danvers right like it's kind of like uh
or the obi-wan criticism right that
there's of not
the obi-wan show or whatever i liked it
we had a lot of miss marvel in the miss
marvel show lisa had a good argument too
in the in this art our interview where
she was saying that you know the show uh
and eric pointed this out too and his
breakdown like it's about kamala getting
the soup from her mom the mask from
bruno the scarf from the red daggers
like her father giving her the name like
and her finding her own identity rather
than being like i'm gonna be just like
carol danvers who flew in and said
you're a good person and tapped me on
the head
and gave me a little sticker
this is about kamala being like her own
person yeah it was kind of a nice full
circle thing she started being inspired
by captain marvel but then really i had
to discover everything to kind of come
back to that whatever the marvel's is
both monica and kamala hating carol
danvers
i would love it i would love it and i'd
watch it over and over again
um speaking of the three so sorry uh are
carol and kamala and monica's power is
related in any way we're getting into
the marvels they're the ones that is
connected
yeah their bands are connected she can
jump through time
all their powers are different and i was
fighting with brandon
i did have a fight about this we
literally almost got they almost got
physical because whoa and then it almost
got physical
talk about mandatory fun but it um
because i was like i don't think their
powers are all coming from the same
source because we they're so different
and they all got them in such different
ways i could see because i feel like
monica got it from um from wanda but
then you mentioned what if monica was a
mutant um
what if carol's immunity
she survives the blast from the
tesseract
maybe the her mutant gene gave her the
ability to absorb that energy yeah maybe
monica's mutant gene is activated by
going through the mutants have been here
the whole time i also think so space
stone via tesseract powers up uh uh
carol danvers uh mind stone via
uh hex via scarlet which via hex powers
up monica is there an infinity stone
somehow
what's the purple blue gem what's the
purple's power power jab the power jam i
mean you pointed out like she did travel
through time which i don't know if that
was the nord dimension if it was it
wasn't purple
when she falls the first time at it
yes i mean is there also potential
because it is like they're gonna be the
marvels or at least that's the title of
the film like what if they don't need to
be that connected and really their
connection is the fact they all end up
in the same place fighting the same
battle together right and they're it's
more like a a team in the the sense that
like well the x-men
didn't all get their powers the same way
it's all from a mutation but it wasn't
like
in the same place not the same powers
yeah the only reason i also would like
is just because i'm like
i don't like that like monica was so
close to carol yeah and it's like okay
these two people got powers the mom
didn't but like these two are mutants
i'm not buying it yeah i don't like that
but i mean it could be true it could be
true i also do agree with yours that
it's just like monica and carol are so
close and then we have this third party
character kamala who's just obsessed
with carol so it's like i'm a part of
this too
that's a fun dynamic right like yeah
she's gonna be like the much younger fan
girl also yeah like monica's been like
an agent like she's a professional woman
like she's got her stuff together right
like uh and then there's a teenage girl
also hanging out with them that's weird
right also how old how old is carol in
2025 i know she's asian different out in
space with all her magical people well
you think she's going forward also in
certain circumstances
she's old as hell right yeah what was
the movie
in the 90s and she's like right when the
movie is set and she's already old
enough to be a fighter pilot yeah she's
like 29 late 20s early 30s assuming
she's 28. so so again not biologically
necessarily but but chronologically
she's in her
like aging slower because of yes
just saying the creativity we'll say the
question i always say
in the clear yeah
that's exactly what i was about to say
you got me gosh i was thinking of which
we're going to talk about geology in a
minute but right now if you want to look
great and stay young for a long time uh
why not try athletic greens
we've all been drinking our athletic
greens our ag-1 yeah because we want
that better gut health and we want to
have more energy uh tommy's been having
it for a while zach's been drinking it
for a while i've been drinking it uh
it's good it tastes great and all you
need is one scoop of this ag ag-1 in a
thing of water and it gives you tons of
stuff uh it gives you
all like 75 high quality vitamins
minerals whole food source superfoods
probiotics adaptogens all the good
things that start your day right it can
be the first thing you drink in the
morning have it on an empty stomach uh
it's supposed to coat your stomach and
help you absorb your your stuff
throughout the day it's great it helps
your nervous system your immune system
energy focus aging all that stuff and
there's less of one gram of sugar no
gmos no nasty chemicals are artificial
anything i think gmos you're supposed to
pronounce that huh i think you're
supposed to pronounce gmos
that's right
no chemos no gemos
hey jamo get out of here uh they they're
always improving the formula testing it
making sure it's great
well-sourced ingredients you can trust
it it's time to reclaim your health arm
your immune system with this convenient
daily nutrition it's just one scoop in a
cup of water every day that's it you
don't need a million different pills all
those supplements you don't have to have
them laid out like a crazy person don't
worry about it just drink this athletic
greens is gonna give you a free one-year
supply of immune supporting vitamin d
and five free travel packs with your
first purchase all you're going to do is
visit
athleticgreens.combreakroom again that's
atlanticgreens.com
to take ownership over your health and
pick up the ultimate daily nutritional
insurance thank you athletic greens
where athletic greens hopes you're on
the inside i'm going to help you on the
outside
there is one thing all the hues need the
geologies over there there's one thing
that all these heroes have in common and
that's great skin yeah which makes sense
because you don't want to dry flaky skin
when you're going to be on the news all
the time ask me about it so if you
wanted that heroic radiant glow you got
to work on the skin care routine you
guys and that's where geology comes in
the fine folks at geology hooked us up
with some skincare products that i've
loved
that i've loved tommy's having a hard
time opening it but i promise it is
still good but you got to be some kind
of
marine biologist oh god geology
there you go baby geology is a nine-time
award-winning men's skincare company
that creates simple effective
personalized skincare products for me oh
my god i feel amazing yeah baby it's
it's entering my pores okay i'm getting
strong
oh that baby face just got babier
vital morning face cream it's past noon
time oh no
morning my face
my beautiful
my beautiful
click the link in the video's
description and take a 30 second quiz
tell them about your skin and their team
of dermatologist designs or regimen just
for you that ships directly to your door
it's great for folks worried about acne
dark eye circles
wrinkles are signs of aging
uh they send you a 30-day trial set
that's easy to incorporate into your
routine whether you're new to skincare
or a seasoned expert like zach right now
we have we have some of their products
they sent here they all are they're
beautiful what do you got face wash
everyday face wash i got everyday
facebook okay
face scream is already a part of my life
and by the way for me 337 that is the
morning
preparing night cream there you go
for sure because i am torn up by the end
of the day oh baby stem to stern they're
great they're offering a crazy deal
right now you can get 70 off on their
30-day five-piece trial kit head to
geology.com to get a 70 off on your
30-day trial when you use the code
rockstar 70 or just click the link below
that's geology.com promo code rockstar
70 to save 70 off on your 30-day trial
wow
thank you to geology athletic greens and
hellofresh for helping us uh we're very
lucky to have three sponsors for this uh
show which helps us bring the show to
you now that we got the business out of
the way yeah maybe it's time for a
little mandatory fun
that's right the segment
that gets us in so much trouble we play
the graphic double
again
the
segment that brings such a tremendous
ripple we play the graphic triple play
it again got it on the nipple yes that's
right mandatory fun the segment that
works on all of our dad pods so much
that we play the graphic dead quad
oh the graphic my eyes aren't so good so
sometimes i have to squint so we must
play this graphic quit
oh the again that makes me feel like the
segment is under a hex so i play this
segment
this time sex
yeah
this is sexy
this sex is a pretty big thing
sex
my good friend and gremlins director joe
dante launched a bit of a tirade against
everyone's favorite jedi mandalorian
young ling foundlin grogu aka baby yoda
aka b-y aka little baby yo-yo
so we've decided as the official uh
you know uh pr firm of joe dante we'd
have a little in-house trial to decide
if uh if joe dante is correct in saying
that that that baby yoda is just a
rip-off of gizmo i've brought two of the
finest attorneys here today to argue the
case unfortunately this is crazy
i can't be here no no no tommy this is
true i'm so sorry i have to go
uh i am actually i am getting a komodo
dragon
uh spleen put in now a spleen is an
organ you can live without but i've been
told that my my spleen is what they were
they referred to as a traumatic spleen
my spleen has been traumatized from
years of misuse and abuse so i'm getting
a komodo dragon spleen put in by my uh
my doctor dr manuel
uh manuel makorski uh at mccorsky
cosmetic surgery and he will be
replacing my spleen so i've got a great
substitute to come in and be the judge
today jessica will be the jury and by
the way
the judge can be bought so if you've got
a vote between grogu and gizmo
pony up some dough in a super chat and
we'll count that towards the job
you're the jury and the judge will
decide if he likes the jury anyway okay
well we uh um as we wait for the judge
uh to arrive my name is uh uh z
huddleston esquire uh i will be
taking the side today of grogu okay uh
um prosecuting joe dante for his slander
of america's uh famous foundling well as
barrister brandon berg i'm prosecuting
you there's no defense on this there's
just two prosecutions okay i'm accusing
grogu of heinously copyrighting my boy
gizmo the mogwai whoa you're out of
order you're adamantly you're out of
them
ordering the court
order in the car oh now it is i
t michael beck told judge jury and
executionist i don't we don't even
execute judge jerry and sexecutioner oh
god it's like paul newman once told me
at the roosevelt i'd rather have four
threes than 112. is this a graduation
gap
don't worry about it
some people didn't use their graduation
gowns i know a lot of you recognize me
as hollywood mover and shaker but not a
lot of you know i serve some time as a
tv judge
on the smash hit judge what
the wackiest courtroom show of all time
where i made decisions based on feelings
emotions games of chance lottery tickets
all right boys which one of you wants to
go first brandon why don't you uh i've
got a very strong case here and i don't
i don't think there'll be any any need
to hear the other side's argument okay
first of all
what is gizmo start with a g
what does grogu start with a g dare over
here that's true gizmo
comes in at one foot tall what does a
little baby yoda come in at
one foot one inch tall off jackson
thank you thank you perseus uh big eyes
big eyes wow pointy ears pointy ears
okay they both have issues with food you
can't feed this boy after midnight you
can't feed this boy anything yeah a
murderer he ate children he ate children
that's right uh uh uh they're both
possibly hairy we don't know what
no visible hair look at these fingers
claw claw claw-like fingers uh uh and
they both they both have a very odd
speech pattern that you cannot make out
intelligibly now i have a witness
uh who who will testify on behalf of the
prosecutor what what the surprise
witness the voice the voice
the voice of modbuy himself
uh
we have if we have the
uh
i agree with you
[Music]
mr dante
himself the prosecution well also quick
uh disclaimer uh be careful following uh
i love him
let me put it this way google howie
mandel tick tock deleted and treat
yourself to some waste down paradise
now that prosecution's case just made my
balls come out of my throat to dribble
them like a basketball before i shot him
back in speaking of balls
one time at the chateau marmont joe
dante and i split a nine bills this is
why no one has any uh faith in uh our
traditional institutions i know a nine
ball is an eight ball plus a can of rc
cola okay
we're gonna impeach the break room court
real quick okay but uh luckily this is a
pretty open and shut case okay i want to
defend grogo here and it's it's not hard
to do okay first off
character design right there's only so
many archetypes of a character right oh
oh oh you've got a copyright on tiny and
cuddly i think not okay also the fur
verse no for debate don't say that
there's a lot of fur under his cloak as
far as we know people have uh of uh or
creatures of the grogu yoda species are
not foreign
not one of our sponsors
and in addition to that right again this
is a common archetype it would be like
uh somebody creating a bear character
and saying that um they were a ripoff of
smokey or um
uh the country bears or any other beer
cakes i love their jamboree yes perseus
likes to peck at people's head today uh
i too have some pieces of evidence what
um i was able to get a 90s comedian
bobcat gold rate no no no no
i wish the voice of roku no in fact just
to point out how common this archetype
of character with this kind of general
size demeanor head shape everything is
i present
evidence
image number one
oh my god stitch from lilo and stitch
okay that looks a lot like gizmo and
grow good
let's see image number two
whoa a furby everybody had one in 1998
okay you learned words and sat on your
shelf you got tired of it after a week
okay same shape same general vibe and
finally
that is an actual creature okay this is
thanks uh producer daschle found this
image this is a south asian langer i
believe it's a tiny monkey type creature
but that as quoted by joe dante inspired
the original
look of gizmo okay
you can't steal what's already been
stolen okay
and i'm listening i will say this i once
dated a furby but i lost it inside of me
in 2002 so we parted ways i don't think
you did it still inside you well we'll
see about that jessica it's time for you
and i to deliberate okay
okay how does the jury find the jury
rules in favor
the judge will withhold this and i
sentence brandon barrick what
electric chair oh whoa
that sounds fun
don't don't wet the sponge
that's one hour with team michael
bechtold anything goes
anyway i've got to go i'm due for my own
court appearance turns out i haven't
paid child support in 50 years wait what
i don't think you have to pay after
they're 50 years old wait a minute my
children donate children doesn't have
free technology well i think we got to
set up that was the barber shop now yeah
it's time for the barber shop i'll get
it set up but it's almost fun you guys
have such a good job
oh thank you that was a lot of fun and
and yeah i don't know
uh hey guys sorry i'm back what are you
doing tommy you missed a fun
mandatory fun how was the judge we
defended uh he was a little unhinged
they were also reporting to the police
for not paying child support for 50
years i also do like there was a little
bit of info there joe dante uh there is
a um a gremlins series coming out i
think sometimes soon he's out on the
trail kind of promoting that so i think
this might have been a little bit of
like stir up some drama to promote your
show which hey i have nothing against no
um okay as we mentioned at the beginning
of this episode as we've been talking
about all week long
if we were able to raise a thousand
dollars in super chats oh and we have by
the way we have unlocked another swear
oh i'm gonna i think it's fair since
tommy is undergoing a uh a haircut that
we allow tommy to use this square
however he says he's gonna want it you
can pocket it until you see the results
i'm gonna pocket it until the haircut's
done um but if we were able to raise a
thousand bucks this week tommy was gonna
get a haircut live on air we did that
uh thanks to you our wonderful viewers
thanks to folks like miss mcdaddy yuca
prieta jenny davis tiffany nguyen
uh azalea rivera
danny rasiki lots of wonderful food we
gotta thank new master who has
contributed
roughly a quarter of this yes bless your
heart new master you pushed us over that
face but by the way guys i'm getting
this fresh cut
pony up some dough and said me and zach
to the cinema for crying out loud that's
right we're only 898 bucks away from
doing a gentle minions and you know what
i'll even say this
if we can cross one more hundred bucks
we'll roll it over to next week we'll
take this total add it to next week and
then if we can hit two thousand bucks in
two weeks go do a gentle minions okay
now i'm gonna available over here
as you can imagine this is our first
on-air haircut yeah uh so we're learning
as we're going uh they went with the
mohawk jessica the one with the mohawks
oh yeah chat stems for tommy and a lot
of you thank you chad thank you merciful
chat
you will never be forgiven or forgotten
for this and i will forgive you
immediately
while we get set up here uh while
jessica gets the the clippers while
tommy says goodbye to his luscious locks
we're going to take some questions
from the chat thank you to everybody uh
throwing in questions super chats
regular questions everything um azalea
rivera asking how do you think kamala
will meet carol and monica so we know
they're existing in the same universe
they're swapping places how will they
join i mean if they have to go get her
in the negative zone that might be the
moment when they meet i don't know maybe
maybe at least for the beginning of that
movie kamala is kind of the macguffin
we've got to go save this girl yeah yeah
yeah yeah i like that as an idea tiffany
said in a super chat what video are you
dying to make on the channel also jess
is the heart soul and dumb of this
channel which is very true and jessica's
got a video coming out this weekend that
she's so excited about saturday um i did
a breakdown for season three of the boys
and thank you for everybody in the chat
that kept constantly harassing people
for me to do a breakdown yeah the video
i want to make is every big question i
make and watch them watch them all yes
shout outs all the great work brandon
does on the big question series um you
know i don't make videos on the channel
other than the break room series that
we're making right now but if i did yeah
in some alternate world i just watched
over the weekend the movie x the new
thai west horror film oh yeah really
enjoyed it i would i wouldn't mind if
new rockstars covered a little bit more
horror uh film if you're a horrifying
rock star yeah if you like horror flicks
uh scary flicks thrillers chillers and
skrillers uh throw that in the chat
what's a recent horror movie you'd love
to see us break down okay
uh-oh okay now
i've heard conflicting reports on
jessica's experience cutting hair
just from her technique so far i feel
good about it she's doing a great job
she's really good at this uh darko lemo
women had asked have you all checked out
the disney cruise marvel exclusive video
miss marvel teams up with wasp captain
america and ant-man and addresses thanos
uh i have not seen this i did hear about
this in uh aman valani on her ama i
believe talked about this a little bit
where they were like what was it like
doing that she was like it was kind of
crazy i think that's where she met
carol or like out uh allison bringing in
real life for the first time
she was like i was just like on a green
screen there were some boxes i'm hopping
around and there's like this orange
square is uh captain america sam wilson
like talk to it or whatever wow because
i think they have like an experience on
the cruise ship i don't know if that's
considered canon i don't think the park
stuff is canon because every time i'm at
disneyland and uh you know natasha's
walking around it's a little unsettling
yeah yeah technically dead tony stark's
still walking around uh at avengers
campus no no one dies in avengers
campaign well technically nobody dies at
disney yeah
what's what's really crazy is that if
you go to the goodfellas theme park
joe pesci is walking around he is still
the real job
don't you mean ray liotta well i i just
mean the character
tommy
tommy tommy bats or what no billy bat
anyways yeah tommy yeah uh brandon
talking about iman villani doing some
green screen acting tommy in your acting
career have you ever done any green
screen work i have i
did green screen work on the show
hunters which has not come out yet where
we filmed inside and outside so we
filmed inside to look outside and we
actually doubled the front of an old
house
in the sound stage with green screen all
around it and when i did abbott
elementary we went up in a hot air
balloon we were actually just up on a
giant green completely covered in green
screen sound stage with a pedestal i'm
sure this has all sounded great with
that i'm so sorry you're so sorry emmy
emmy nominated abbott elementary that's
right quinn the three nominations uh
as well as the uh much of the other cast
uh and fan of the show a fan of your
rock size quinton brunson oh wow
uh very kindly reached out to me after i
filmed my episode my scene was with her
and she dm me and said that eric voss is
a household name oh
hey anytime you want to come on the show
emmy nominated bronson bring back the
balloon operator come on
come on you know what they say you can't
put your tummy on a pedestal i keep
saying it all the time you go to camera
four i feel like we were like let's do
mohawk and i'm serving too much mullet
give him mohawk because i don't do the
mohawk you're in charge you got it right
to shave the gutter yeah what
um oh we've got some other good uh super
chat questions miss mack daddy had asked
us what would you all name weed strands
based on mcu heroes also love you jess
hashtag black girl magic oh thank you
yeah if you could have some good uh uh
weed strains like
you need to i think like the tech is
good to do like pin particles you can
make it oh it's right there pin
particles yeah pim particles yeah
that's that's your whole dispensary
there yeah yeah pen particles um
yeah
i would create the i love you 3000 which
after you smoke it you think you
you think you've died so you deliver
heartfelt messages to your family you're
so high you're like
i'm sorry that i died from smoking this
bomb weed
i want you to know that you should go on
and live a happy life
i want you to go out there and try new
things i love you 3 000.
i like that that's a good one that's a
good one i i've been trying to think of
uh i've i've now spent two minutes
trying to think of a pun for like og
kush yeah um i think you gotta have hail
hydro it's hydroponically grown wheat
you gotta have hail hydro uh
have a little bit of uh uh
old truck you could have like i think
ultron og no well this is great
absolutely
those are a couple good options uh
butchered that said well ganja forever
that exists
that already exists that might exist out
there uh ghost hulk uh that's it's uh
some pretty good ones ragnarok
i mean you throw a g on on the end of
anything boom you got ragna croc would
be the uh the illegal russian magna
chronic
ragna crown name yeah
there's something in there it's a
stretch high-end group i mean loki og is
has a ring to it loki og oh i do like
that um okay we got a lot of folks uh
throwing in super chats about the
haircut people are loving the haircut
guardians
wax wax shatter
cushmonger that's a good one i like i
like cushmonger
um do you guys think the movie uh miss
marvels will be connected to multiverses
do you think they're gonna get into that
i mean this whole phase is all about
like different universes and dimensions
i think if any if it's any multiversal
thing i like i love this like negative
zone idea
that that i will touch on that uh and it
feels like they'll give us we'll fix
those lettuce
perfect
do you think they might um go back to
the newer dimension
i don't know i don't know what to deal
with i would love it if the nord
dimension turns out to be the negative
zone
sure like they call it the north
dimension we have the negative zone yeah
yeah yeah oh yeah that's a good
um
um
uh danny raziski had asked will any miss
marvel supporting cast such as bruno
return for the marvels
i can see bruno coming back i think they
get ty bruno into like iron heart right
yes i know she goes to mit and he's
going to cal talk
but if they both get involved in some
sort of like program
that maybe deals with like wakanda you
know like that could be very interesting
to put all these smarty pants together
it is interesting they made such a big
plot point out of caltech yeah right
like that's gonna be important somehow
well we have talked about how they keep
building up these like west coast
avengers stuff where you have like
ant-man and sean chi are both based in
san francisco they're doing more stuff
in california i mean iron man used to be
based out of yeah
yeah put more west coasters out there we
love to see it we love to see it how do
the ten rings connect to the bengal
that's from our friend frey girl um we
we never got that connection outright
right we saw the logo for the ten rings
on the floor of the tomb or whatever
where the bengal was
um but we never found out exactly what
that connection was like mts this whole
theory of this like they're part of some
set of like cosmic jewelry almost uh
that that has some importance wait a
second wait a second u.s agent bong
smoker
that's
wait stop laughing have you been
thinking about that for like five
minutes
more
[Laughter]
uh but yeah the idea like the cree built
both the bengals and the the rings i
don't know
it does feel like when they had that
line in shanghai where it's like it's
calling out to something they maybe
didn't know what that something was yeah
uh i don't know but
it is going to be interesting to see how
they all connect i still want to know
did the bengal activate her mutation was
the mutation always there
uh would she have been able to do
the control but
that doesn't instill a ton of confidence
the nor light without the bengal
is that something like the hard light
would she be able to do that if she
never touched the bengal is it like a
mental thing
well and can they now retcon and say
that like lots of mutants were kind of
like laying in wait until some kind of
stimuli activated their powers like the
bengal might have done for uh
um
miss marvel maybe i was saying this is
not going to happen but they could do
this under this logic what if they say
bruce banner had some kind of mutation
that the gamma radiation unlocked yeah
right um you could say that for almost
any powered individual yeah in this game
like they've kind of hinted that you
know scarlet witch had chaos magic
something as a child right she stops the
bomb from exploding yeah and even in
that same sequence her brother maybe
pulled her away really fast
but didn't even realize he did it uh
because it was you know he was just
acting on instinct or something like
that that trauma activated his his x
gene his mutation uh yeah i think they
will be able to definitely write kanye
and a bunch of mutants
i just do not want them to be like oh
the school's been here the whole time
yeah there's been this like school of
gifted children i don't want that uh and
it would be interesting to have a
magneto
starts now
didn't live through
number two yeah i mean even now it's
almost impossible to have a magneto that
lived through world war ii and the
events of that
uh and not be no again it has to be like
if
is looking great for a 50 year old we
could say magneto's aging slower than
normal people too but um i would love
just like to start from scratch well
with
here's one thing i've been thinking
about we have all of next week obviously
comic-con is not this upcoming weekend
but the weekend after so a lot next week
there'll be some news coming out we'll
be talking about comic con and then the
week after we'll be talking a lot about
comic-con but i want to talk right now
let's do early predictions just based on
the end of miss marvel the end of thor
um some of the hints the interviews that
have been happening what's your marvel
prediction for an announcement at comic
con oh like a big announcement
now it was debunked anybody that's way
too on the internet like us yeah knows
that like there was this rumor of all
these big announcements that was going
to happen it's been debunked by marvel
and by everybody involved and it was
kind of easy to debunk if you would but
um but we want to try to go out on a
limb i mean i think you know we kind of
forever trailer that's pretty we're
gonna get that uh i think if they have
like a big new announcement it would be
they'll con because there's some
properties down the line that are just
like marvel project marvel projects yeah
i think like something like
midnight suns
them like kind of confirming it or being
like here's your next ghost writer right
like they love to make a reveal of a new
person is going to play a character in
an upcoming project yes especially a big
character right we got the mahershala
ali as blade right um yeah and we
haven't gotten any that was in the the
debunked league it's really nice you
look really i know jessica you're doing
this you're doing a worse job
i'm
now can you give us a side angle so we
can see a little bit yeah it's really
coming in okay
i'm gonna i'm trying to do the sideburns
but okay tommy's hair is also so thick
it's you know what i'm saying dog you're
getting the flock you guys are getting a
little view of each one that we did you
know what they say about thick hair
uh hard to cut
some people in the chat throwing out
their predictions uh someone said javier
bardem as dr doom would be so good
so good little anton [ __ ] oh yeah
yeah that would be good
what's the most you've ever lost what's
the most trouble
so good uh people saying uh ghost rider
more moon night
um
doctor doom movie
all right it could be a lot of fun
um
yeah it does feel like not only are we
gonna get some more about the projects
we know are happening obviously uh
wakanda forever the marvel's uh quantum
mania right those are kind of the next
three
uh theatrical films right like so maybe
we get more news about whatever's
happening after that also we know about
some of the upcoming disney plus shows
we know that um obviously she-hulk and
then um secret invasion are coming up
this year and we know like iron wars
loki season two rdn production do we
know anything beyond that as far as
things that have been uh
talked about in production everything
season two coming out of season two
uh there's like this werewolf by night
the special special we haven't heard
anything about more the guardian special
guardians three as well yeah um i think
that's all the shows we know about
picking up the top of my head um and
whatever x-men 97 is gonna be if that
maybe has like bigger consequences now
because they have teased the whole thing
that like animated stuff
can become live action or because they
they said like the what if stuff is
canon it's just like different universes
different universes and they were saying
that those characters could become live
action now they were saying a lot of
that to set up multiverse of madness
yeah to be like here's why there's a
captain carter here's why there's a evil
doctor strange or whatever because these
things can exist but those weren't the
same ones we saw
in whatevs so i don't know
but it would be interesting if x-men 97
has some implication if that's how
they're going to bring some over some
people over
uh making mutants
um it does help a lot of casting if you
don't need to recast wolverine you could
just have him be animated like cory yeah
wait on i don't need a wolverine take
your time on wolverine uh cora jamison
had said the celestial energy released
by tiamat's body is what unlocks the
mutant gene around the world i love that
idea i love the idea and we had
theorized this years ago that one of the
many snaps yes messed up everything or
like release so much gamma radiation
that affects uh the x gene i mean if
they wanted to go ultra grounded
climate change maybe climate change
microplastics are the new x gene we've
all got them we've all got i can't do
that dead kennedy's guy yeah yeah that's
a um he called it the death lock
is uh instead of a dreadlock um
uh okay uh i'm sad to announce i don't
know that we're gonna get a completion
of a haircut online
we will complete it off the air and i
will post an update to twitter tonight
and then we will put it on there take
time to put on that ticket
the underscore break room yeah for the
final results look at this but uh we
appreciate everybody that donated this
week through his super chats especially
today uh ponder diggins uh ernest damian
here from dickos if that's your real
name send us your birth certificate and
i'll send you five bucks back i'll
here for the cookies if that's your
legal name here for the cookies we'll
send you a bag of cookies uh we
appreciate everybody for joining us here
at the break room all week long we're
gonna be back again next week yeah we're
talking leading up to comic-con right
we'll have all kinds of uh new stuff to
react to a lot of times you get trailers
the week before kind of right right
people want to beat the news i'm talking
about that um also we'll get to all week
long look at um tommy's beautiful might
still be getting his haircut monday
morning it's possible it's possible
that's right all right thank you
everybody oh tommy you never get to use
your profanity oh yeah keep it gucci the
[ __ ] moon yeah
clip it flip it bye